So, here's an issue.
What happens when the size at which you
want to draw a texture is different from
the size the texture actually is?
For instance, this center image is
the actual size of the GigaGal texture.
That's one pixel in the texture
is one pixel on the screen.
Well we have two very different ways
of drawing GigaGal at six times her
normal size.
The way we choose the color of the extra
pixels that are added when we scale up
a texture is called filtering.
On the left, we're using
nearest neighbor interpolation.
That is to say that we
just pick the nearest
pixel in the original image to figure
out what color to color a new pixel.
Over here, we're using linear filtering,
which uses a linear combination of
the nearby pixels to select a new color.
Basically, average it.
Now, in most cases, especially if you're
only making the texture a little bit
bigger, linear filtering will
tend to preserve more detail.
But it's also a little bit more
costly from a graphics point of view.
However, since all the textures for
GigaGal are in this pixel art style,
we'll be using nearest
neighbor interpolation or
nearest neighbor filtering for
most of this class.
LibGDX provides a third type of
filtering called MIP mapping.
And that is where it precomputes a bunch
of versions of the texture at different
scales.
This is most useful when the size of
a texture is going to be changing
dramatically over the course of a game,
which mostly happens in 3D applications.
So we're not going to
worry about it here,